apple the company that pioneered
graphics interfaces in its heyday made
the greatest music player that shaped a
generation and is responsible for the
biggest technological revolution in
decades not to mention at the time of
making this video the most valuable
company in the world requires no
introduction however although you and i
still consider it a tech company over
the past decade or so and largely since
steve jobs influence has faded the
company has begun to shift towards a
much more software and service-based
business model and it looks like the
first major breakthrough away from
computer technology might be on the
horizon today i am going to tell you all
about what might be apple's biggest and
most important release since the iphone
apple's own self-driving car if you are
interested and want to learn more then
gear up in your fancy futuristic seats
and keep watching till the end
project titan
now this part of the deal is still a
little rough but we can still guess a
lot from what we know first off it is
pretty much a given that the car's chip
will be designed in-house and made by
tsmc the taiwanese chipmaker apple also
employs for their iphone and mac chips
for a while it was rumored that apple
might partner with hyundai kia to make
the automobile bits of the car with
reported plans for a 3.6 billion dollar
investment in keto motors however in
february of this year those companies
came clean that the deal did not go
through and so that question is still in
the air however what we can tell you is
what isn't in the air and that's the
hirings from a climate system expert
from volvo car ab a sensor engineer from
general motors companies cruise llc and
multiple other engineers from tesla of
all places it seems to me that they are
now planning to do everything in-house
and with apple's ai and machine learning
chief john giandria the man who will
probably be responsible for getting the
software part of the thing settled
finally joining the team as well i think
they can pull it off and honestly if
they managed to do it i'm pretty sure
they will be successful because while
tesla is too engrossed in the ev side of
things and their other competitors like
alphabet's waymo focusing only on
software as apple's exec mark german
himself put it the kinds of things we
love to work on are those where there's
a requirement of hardware software and
services to come together magic occurs
at that intersection
the timeline
although fans have always speculated
about what an apple car may look like
for the longest time that was always
brushed away as fanboy talk however
everything became clearer in february of
2015 when a mysterious van that was
reported to belong to apple was spotted
in northern california which as you may
know is the home of apple itself and
what exactly was it that got this van
labeled as mysterious well as it turns
out the otherwise simple black van had
something massive and unseemly attached
to the top namely a camera rig and one
with multiple cameras and while at the
time most people thought that this was
something akin to google street view
others began to think something more
serious was afoot however the presence
of drivers in the vans and apple's
insistence that all of it was related to
their maps quickly squashed those rumors
but as it would be later revealed those
few people weren't in the wrong as
according to the most recent reports it
was back in 2014 that apple officially
gave birth to project titan which you
guessed it is the name given to their
automotive initiative according to the
wall street journal their sources claim
that at that time apple already had
hundreds of employees working on this
so-called project titan and not only
that they seemed pretty serious about it
too with steve zadesky apple vp of
product design leading the project under
dan riccio apple's head of hardware
engineering now the next few years
remained quiet and it was only two years
later in 2016 that apple next opened up
about the project steve zadesky
announced his plans to exit the project
and soon afterwards in july the former
apple exec bob mansfield who had retired
from the company earlier in 2012
rejoined as the project's new head and
finally in june of 2017 apple's upper
management finally opened up regarding
it with ceo tim cook himself speaking
about and as a result confirming the
rumor that the project was in fact real
we're focusing on autonomous systems
it's a core technology that we view as
very important we sort of see it as the
mother of all ai projects it's probably
one of the most difficult ai projects to
actually work on now this actually
happened because of software regulations
requiring a lot more publicity but
whatever the matter may be it worked and
since then more and more cars have been
spotted all over the country all
seemingly gathering data and testing the
required information while the past two
years have been a bit of a wrench in
well everyone's plans with big companies
like apple taking a hit too it's no
secret that the project has taken a
while to get a date
all the rumors
just this week reporters from bloomberg
revealed that the california tech giant
is looking to not only hasten its
efforts toward the car but has started
to finally realize what the project will
look like you see for the longest time
the project was just meant as an
exploration of different options with
the two main ones being a car that sold
because of its electric nature with
performance and speed being at selling
points or one that focused on being able
to drive without human intervention and
as we've already mentioned they seem to
have decided what exactly it is they're
going to do with the article claiming
that under the leadership of apple watch
software executive kevin lynch the
company developers are now focusing
solely on the second option according to
the site's sources unlike tesla and
other electric cars which are only
slowly increasing the self-driving
functionality of already existing cars
apple is instead trying to push towards
a car that has a fully self-driving
system in the first version this is big
news guys because while the project has
been on and off since 2014 we finally
seem to be getting confirmation that the
company is taking this seriously there
have in fact been multiple indications
of them doing just that starting in
september of this year apple's former
head of the project doug field after
three years in charge just left for a
seemingly more attractive job at ford
motor company who we can safely assume
are working on self-driving cars of
their own and as a replacement apple
picked their own executive the
aforementioned lynch not only that there
have been job listings for that project
as well with a recent job listing
reading that the special projects group
is seeking an accomplished mechanical
engineer to lead the development of
mechanical systems with safety critical
functions you will use your passion for
figuring things out to help design
safety systems and to lead the testing
and countermeasures of those systems and
that's pretty big news because let's
face it as much as a thousand people
sound awesome that's nowhere near the
usual amount of people employed for
ventures like these and so you can now
expect the project to grow much larger
in scope as well as manpower all of
which obviously bodes well for the
project in fact the news is so big that
as soon as it was reported apple shares
gained as much as 2.4 percent to
157.23 cents per share what does this
mean for apple
the electric car world may seem to us a
pretty recent craze however the fact of
the matter is that the world's biggest
companies have been trying to get into
the business for a while now because
let's face it we all know that the
future however it may happen will be
electric but an electric car is only
half of the story because you see while
we did say that apple will be moving
away from its roots it doesn't mean
they'll be cutting off their original
strengths in fact far from it because
while their most obvious competitors
like tesla might have a lot of
experience in hardware and stuff apple
has spent a lot of time developing and
honing an entirely different skill set
software and so when you combine those
two things the answer becomes clear and
the rumored vehicle starts to look a
little less blurry and so on that note
i'm going to leave you for today i hope
you enjoyed watching and if you did be
sure to leave a like and subscribe for
more with that take care and i'll see
you guys next time
[Music]
you